this does make me realize about the
person who
isn't on the list but the person who
named their their baby after me have we
told that story
we haven't talked about the story yeah
so back in like when i was really doing
black butler a lot
there was this one person um who
oh this was it i remember i just
remembered the canonical order in my
head
um i went to the black butler meetup the
canonical
this is head canon they're saying the
filler art
so what happened was i this was like my
first ever ax and i can't remember how
long
i was doing youtube for but i thought it
would be cool just to go to the black
butler meetup and just like be
like say hi hey man like yeah i'm i'm
the guy on youtube
butler stuff right right um and just say
hi and just you know
it was just to meet them and just meet
all the fans of black belter and be like
yeah this is [ __ ] sick and they're
all really nice and there's one person
who's like
really really nice super super nice
and um yeah and she was really nice we
got loads of pictures with her and she's
a little intense you know but that's
fine i'm used to that yeah i mean all
black butler fans are quite intense
yeah yeah but like some of them are like
some of them just there don't give a
[ __ ] about
you know like like watching my videos
anybody but there was a good i'd say
like half there were like oh my god
because you were the black butler guy
back then well yeah i mean i i says of
youtube i was the only one making
content about black butler yeah
because it was like how many years after
black butler dead and yeah i feel like i
almost made like a mini like renaissance
of the fact yeah yeah yeah
in terms of western yeah um like the
community
became way more active and like kind of
like what
uh yugo the bridge series did for the
yu-gi-oh anime back in the day i mean i
i don't want to say it was like
no not heavy but like i feel like it was
definitely a bump because of all the
black belts i was pumped yeah
the stuff but anyway so a year goes by
right and i go to the
you know they're they're messaging me
telling me oh you have to come back to
the blackboard let me meet up again i
have a big surprise for you
and so i'm like all right okay sure i
thought it was like a gift or something
they're making out to be yes i was like
okay sure i'll get it i'll take a
picture
i'll come why not this is the point
where i'm trying to distance myself from
black butler
i was like okay cool i'll i'll come and
so i go
uh yeah lord behold she's holding the
baby like literally like two-month-old
baby i don't know how old this baby is
fresh fresh baby fresh baby fresh out
the oven fresh
freshly made baby single wrinkle on this
baby
and she's like oh do you want to hold
connor
i'm like connor i'm like oh that's a
funny coincidence
i said oh no it's not a coincidence i
named him after you and i'm like
okay this is [ __ ] weird this is
[ __ ] weird
my favorite ever photo is of you holding
baby connor
with the most uncomfortable smile i've
ever seen how much how did you even
react to that
uh just pure confusion and again you
gotta understand god i just go with
everything
yeah his face all the babies like i mean
i would do exactly the same thing i
wanted the picture to reflect like how
uncomfortable i am yeah so that i could
i could like tell the story later on
now yes there's a picture out there if
you just google connor with baby maybe i
don't [ __ ] know what's going on with
baby
dog baby well i don't know what the [ __ ]
comes up
c dog v82 was [ __ ] cute
yeah but like there's something wholly
uncomfortable about holding a stranger's
baby that i just
i don't know it's like holding someone's
expensive vars you know it's like
i still don't know how to handle babies
i i'm like someone asked me if i want to
hold if i want to hold their baby and
i'm just like does it come with an
instruction manual
what do i do like i i feel so inadequate
when it comes to handling babies they're
great for the 10 seconds where they're
not
like crying and then the moment you pick
them up and they start crying i'm like
oh god oh god
what do you think stop please please
stop yeah but like
you know as as odd as that is and and
almost creepy you could say
yeah i mean it's flattering more than
anything i guess but it was i mean don't
get me wrong they were very nice it's
probably flattering in a sense
it's flattering i just i i i would feel
that if anyone named a baby after me
that's a bit that's a bit
too much pressure on me i feel like
naming your baby after any influencer is
a bad idea did you find it mainly
what did you type in
apparently it comes off i just think
it's a bad idea naming your
your baby after any influencer yeah we
all know we're just one bad two yeah
yeah don't name your kid after your
family it's like it's like it's it's
like getting a tattoo
yeah favorite but youtuber luckily
luckily it was just connor and not
sea dog v8 yeah yeah yeah yeah that
would like it i i have i have like no
idea how corpse husband feels whenever
when he sees like his voice like what
what would you call it it's like his
wave file
the waveform of him breathing as a
tattoo i'm just like
man how did you handle that yeah um
yeah so that was that's how that happens
yeah that is very bold indeed that is
very bold